hey what's going on hey what's going on
what's going on with you it's bill
Bert's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday February 19th 2018 oh
my god
two months are almost over this year is
just flying by it is if you live out
here you know you live out here in Los
Feliz it's [ __ ] awesome as opposed
just give us the keys as opposed to
living back east where I guess it's
really [ __ ] cold which is where I'm
about ready to go I'm about ready to go
to Becky's because we're doing the sixth
annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit all
right raising money and raising
awareness for the greatest comedian that
I ever saw alive the sixth annual it's
gonna be a great one I can't wait I fly
out tomorrow I'm already packed I got my
[ __ ] ticket you know I got a nice
midday flight gonna have a good time and
then I'm gonna I'm gonna do a late night
set or some [ __ ] at the Westside comedy
club shake a little bit of the rust off
and go on and try not to embarrass
myself with the level of talent that we
have going on there of course and you
know who out with an added addition this
year the teen idol sensation from the
late great Opie and Anthony show mr. Joe
DeRosa Joe DeRosa half Egyptian 100%
[ __ ] can't wait to see him so anyway so
I'm doing this to do this broadcast in
the afternoon I hung out with my my
family all weekend I had a great time
except for the big fight I had with my
wife other than that it was a great time
you know what I mean and I made you know
it was Ash Wednesday the other day and I
went to church for the first time in a
long time just to see the band they had
that Dixieland band I don't know why
they don't have that
week you know what I mean I would go
every week if they were in the back wow
wow wow badda pepe they do that as
opposed to coming in with that haunting
[ __ ] organ all that [ __ ] you know the
original the original support the troops
first responders the original guilt trip
the Catholic religion if Jesus was alive
today can you imagine the standing
ovation he would get as he walked
through the [ __ ] airport if people
weren't staring at their phones if they
saw you don't I mean anyways plowing
ahead
so it's Ash Wednesday and I've given up
argument with my wife for Lent I'm just
not going to do it
I'm just going to experiment just
completely just I'm just going to
[ __ ] I'm just gonna agree with
everything hey hey you want to do this
horrific time eater that you'll deal
you'll experience absolute no joy and uh
yeah absolutely honey that sounds great
you know I'm already been doing it it's
weirding her out you know cuz we went to
the mall today right who the [ __ ] goes
to the mall on a Sunday guess what
this guy cuz I'm not arguing with my
wife anymore let's go go to the mall
[ __ ] absolutely let's go when
everybody else has the day off to go
right so we go down there it's like I
mean it was like it was Christmas there
was so many [ __ ] people down all the
weeks leading up to Christmas I should
say just a zillion [ __ ] people we
still had a good time alright don't get
me wrong I love my wife I love my kid I
love my role as being a father but jesus
[ __ ] christ
you know what I mean it just gets to the
point man there's just too many [ __ ]
people I start getting like
claustrophobic so
we go down in this place right we're
[ __ ] hanging out and everything and
I'm just looking around I actually glad
I went because I haven't been to a
gathering of people in a long time I
mean I know people come out to my shows
but the lights are in my eyes so I can't
see you and I cannot [ __ ] believe the
influence of social media on just people
walking around it was it was it was a
[ __ ] show I have never seen so much side
boob underneath boob on top boob with my
wife's gonna be stop staring all these
titties it's just like how they're
[ __ ] out everybody looked like they
were trying to do the you know the it
was dress like they were going to a
photo shoot to get their [ __ ]
whatever your your main picture on
Instagram all the guys G queued up or
looking like j.crew doshas I saw this
one work woman walking by and it was
just like she looked like she was on her
way to the club and she was pushing a
baby and I accidentally in front of me I
just killed that's not a mom moms don't
look like that
Sonia's look at me she goes why not
that's what I want to look like I want
to I want to be the hot mom what's wrong
with that and I was just like well I
gave it up for Lent I was like nothing
nothing yeah you're right you're right
she goes dumb no I want to hear what
you're thinking I said now well you know
I gave up arguing with you for I lent so
I you know she goes we don't have to
argue you could just tell me what you
think it it's right off the bat I'm
loving this new power that I have that
I'm not gonna argue with her and then
you know because I'm not arguing with
there she's not gonna know what I'm
thinking right
and that's freaking her out and all I
want to say is hey welcome to my [ __ ]
world I never know what you're thinking
guys I'm talking right now it's not too
late it's not too late give up arguing
with your woman for Lent and this is the
tell them that that's what you're doing
I'm not gonna argue with you and they're
all excited they think it's going to be
great but then is you you're you're like
taking away one of them major powers
which is their ability to piss you off
and then you spill the beans you know
they get you all [ __ ] mad and be like
all right
cuz I had another drink with my friends
you know what cuz I don't [ __ ] break
my balls I can go then she can be like
all that [ __ ] right so if you just said
they just sit in the [ __ ] pocket like
what was that movie John Turturro did we
played that mobster and he just did that
great thing where he just was sitting
there like barely audible in front of
the that whatever some [ __ ] Senate
Committee gonna I can't answer that in
the grounds that might incriminate
myself I can't answer there and the
grounds that might incriminate myself I
can't answer that might incriminate
myself he says it like over and over
there this gravelly [ __ ] voice that
is so [ __ ] on believe that they
should have just given him a reward just
him saying that line over and over again
was better than 90% of the [ __ ] act
and that I see right so anyways she's
trying to get me to [ __ ] say why you
know a woman shouldn't be like [ __ ]
high heels with her ass [ __ ] jacked up
in the air and a tits hanging out you
know makeup all done hair all done all
of that [ __ ] pushing around a kid now
you know there really is no reason why
she can't be like that
I just selfishly was just sitting there
like I wouldn't want my mom to look like
that because then all my friends would
want to [ __ ] my mom you know so much of
what I think makes sense until I say it
out loud and then I realize how [ __ ]
stupid I am but it was I mean granted I
was in LA we went right to the [ __ ]
The Grove here in Hollywood where it's
just like you know there was some of the
best-looking [ __ ] fifth 40 50 and 60
year old people I've ever seen in my
life and then you had the young people
Jesus Christ was all-star weekend you
thought all the [ __ ] were down at the
Staples Center and the [ __ ] hotels in
the surrounding area now they were over
at the Grove the regular ones everybody
there looked like they were trying to
[ __ ] an NBA all-star and none of them
worked
they would just shop it and I caught
myself in a mare and I was just like wow
man
I literally look like I came here in a
[ __ ] time machine I had my old Archie
Bunker hat on and everybody keeps
breaking my balls because I made fun of
Rogen's hat that one time when he said
he had a little rascals haircut on hat
on I was gonna say I love that hat I
just gave him Schick as I thought he was
going to come at me was just a comedian
thing make fun of his [ __ ] hat he'll
be self-conscious he can't see it it's
on top of his head it's gonna [ __ ] with
them and then I won't have to deal with
Joe Rogan unleashing his genius on my
big bald head right that's the only
reason why other than that I like the
Hat so um I got a couple those I got a
little pork pie hat you know I got my
own little [ __ ] mr. white from
[ __ ] Breaking Bad going on you shave
your head as a white dude I mean you got
to cover it up especially if you're a
[ __ ] ginger all right I'm not trying
to spontaneously combust I live in a
desert out here I got to keep the Sun
off me anyways I need to like paint the
top of my you know paint the top of my
head like you know in World War 2 I they
would paint the headlights they'd just
be like a little slit there I should
paint the entire my whole [ __ ] head
and just have a slit right near my eyes
so I don't blind anybody trying to land
at LAX anyways but there was a lie and
then in the middle of all of that
Instagram [ __ ] show which was kidding do
most of this is just me dealing with the
fact that things are changing and nobody
cares about my views which is part of
becoming old they just said nuts right
nobody cares nobody cares old man you
had your time it's [ __ ] over right so
I'm just kind of getting to that
realization that I am that guy I'd
probably been that guy for 15 years but
I've just you know my [ __ ] I don't
know I'm so full of myself I finally
just realized it so I don't know that's
something I mean and I got man I must
have looked like a creep I must look
like a creep I'm 49 years old okay and I
like to think I try to be a gentleman
you know Jesus I try okay but here's the
thing if you're gonna walk by with your
[ __ ] titties out I mean what am I
supposed to do that's my new [ __ ]
you know when I get a text one like some
gumshoe [ __ ] it drives me and nuts and I
love it
I'm [ __ ] winning man I'm not arguing
with her it's driving her nuts
in a little way you know because she
said well we don't have to argue but I
still like debating so I should know
what's going on with you as always my
wife doesn't talk like that that's just
how I hear it my head so anyways we went
over there and I went into the Nike
store and they actually have the balls
they're selling t-shirts that say
equality and I'm thinking like isn't
this two people that was it them or
Apple that had the sweatshop where
people would jump into their deaths I
can't remember but then I looked it up
and it says that Nike has made big
strides no pun intended and they're
[ __ ] sweatshop environment which I
mean I mean what do you have to [ __ ]
do you know give one person a sandwich
and then you get a higher rating than
last quarter I don't know top 10 ways to
improve a sweatshop number one by a
flyswatter one flyswatter for all 10,000
employees number two what else could you
do have a door well people can go home
at some point a working bathroom I don't
know if I don't know if they're all
[ __ ] why did I am you know what I
mean it's so [ __ ] dumb when I was a
kid they made shirts in this country and
it didn't cost you a zillion dollars but
now they just like you wasn't your gonna
go
because that's not because it costs so
[ __ ] much to make a shirt it's
because they're not gonna drop their
profits so it's like I if we can't pay
this guy 30 cents an hour we got to pay
it an American [ __ ] ten bucks an hour
then you're gonna eat the cost in the
shark okay cuz I'm not having a smaller
yacht
you got that [ __ ] oh by the way I gave
to the president's campaign you didn't
so what I say goes
that's how I think good that's how I
think it works without ever having
researched how much it costs to make a
shirt that's how I formulate my opinions
you know I look at a couple things then
I get paranoid and then I just started
running my freckled [ __ ] Yap and for
whatever reason enough people listen to
this podcast that I continue doing it
twice a week alright do you ever think
about that as you sit in your cubicle
giggling and laughing to yourself that
you're just enabling you're just
enabling the the disease of a sick man
maybe I know I think I'm sick I don't
know I don't know what the [ __ ] I am all
I know was the titties were out at the
[ __ ] mall and I was walking around
looking like a skinny Archer punk Archie
Bunker and I don't give a [ __ ] you know
my wife goes but don't don't be [ __ ]
do this one girl walk by right giant ass
giant round [ __ ] ass and she was I
think she bought salami from the white
shadow salami short shorts off of the
white shadow and that's what the [ __ ]
she had on her [ __ ] ass was out I was
like Mia look at that turn around look
at that she goes look at what turn
around she goes Jesus Christ yeah
guys you gotta stick around and raise
your daughters okay I'll tell you right
now if that woman that barely a woman
wearing those [ __ ] shorts if her
dad's stuck around for her entire
childhood childhood I swear to god I'll
have a gun in my mouth if you can be a
good dad and your daughter's still
to the mall with half her [ __ ] ass
hanging out I don't know maybe that's
this is this part of the [ __ ] the me
to thing the empowerment of women you
know that's stupid [ __ ] know where it's
like basically women can now do whatever
the [ __ ] they want without consequence
you know ignoring the number one [ __ ]
rule of nature which is you have the way
you wish the world is and the way the
world really is and you have to act
accordingly you could walk around with
your ass hanging out I wouldn't do it
that's not something I would do but you
know it is your ass and if you want to
have it out over that George Carlin book
bit that he did he goes you ever noticed
90% of women who ever were against
abortion you wouldn't want to [ __ ] in
the first place
it's one of my favorite flats just
[ __ ] hilarious you know that's a lot
of times when you sit there and you
think you know women are bitching about
being catcalled some of the [ __ ]
women whose [ __ ] complain about that
[ __ ] you're just looking at him going
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
kidding me I swear to god you walk by a
construction site Lenny in here is the
sound of people hammer and nails you
know if you [ __ ] high horse you know
well maybe that's because I'm not
exactly a good-looking person and I
don't have sympathy for people who get
like a standing ovation when they walk
by a [ __ ] jobsite am I really
supposed to feel bad for you
I understand it's scary I always looked
at it like you know like whenever is a
guy you watch like the beginning of
Shawshank Redemption and everyone's
chanting fresh fish
that's much be what like you know a
certain you know level of good looking
woman feels like when she walks by a
construction site however in 2018 all
women seem to be acting like they're
that good-looking and the reality is
you're not okay which brings me to
Olympic figure skating all right if I
hear one more [ __ ] figure skater
talking about how they had to starve
themselves because they weren't
right body type to [ __ ] twirl around
in the [ __ ] ice I mean am I really
supposed to feel bad for you okay you've
entered a [ __ ] beauty contest all
right I swear to god it'd be like you
know listen to some of these people
complaint is like me bitching that I
can't book a shampoo commercial or how
come I can't be the spokesperson for
Coppertone tanning because you're a bald
pasty freckled [ __ ] that no one wants to
look at we're in business here we're
trying to make money right so I don't
like that that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
her you know I'd love that I don't even
know her name
oh no Tonya Harding I guess I don't know
the yellow ones named Nancy Kerrigan I
know both you don't I mean that was just
all about a little [ __ ] runt of the
litter chick all right who should have
been like a powerlifter or something and
she decided that she was gonna figure
skate I mean they have figure right in
the [ __ ] job you got to be all long
and [ __ ] sinewy everybody knows that
I don't I don't [ __ ] get it I haven't
have you got it like [ __ ] you got to
like dumb it down there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] going on right now
I heard Sports Illustrated use nothing
but women's photographers this year is
some sort of sign of strength of women
it's just like well wait a minute so all
those guys who used to hire did any of
them get busted for doing anything wrong
or did they just all get kicked to the
curb I'm not buying any of this either
now everybody has to like do something
this is like the vagina version of like
the [ __ ] ice bucket challenge it's
like why can't I just give you money
what am I gonna dump [ __ ] over my
[ __ ] head what's the cause is it
worthy is the money actually going to
the victims fine I'll give it to these
stupid shows a strength I don't know god
I'm in a [ __ ] mood so Friday night I
me and my wife went down to go see black
pants
all right and I enjoyed the movie
Neil loved the movie I enjoyed it but
you know I had a little sippy-sip before
I went in there and then I had two hits
a week and it's just a weed that they
make nowadays it's just you know I'm
trying not to drink I don't want the
calories right so I had a couple hits a
wheat and I was just I was like tripping
so I'm sitting in that [ __ ] movie
right and you know deal it's a [ __ ]
superhero movie right and everybody's
just like there's always this big drama
with your family and all of that [ __ ]
and at one point I fell asleep noting
that because of the movie was because I
was [ __ ] flying and I fell asleep for
I don't know how long and all of a
sudden something big and metal got
thrown or crashed and it hit the ground
it was like it was like scraping and
[ __ ] and in my brain I was flying a
helicopter and my skids hit the [ __ ]
runway when I was trying to taxi and I
thought I was gonna flip the [ __ ]
thing and do and I tell you I [ __ ]
jumped [ __ ] like myself up and knee
is looking at me like Jesus Christ it
wasn't that scary but anyways Nia's
gonna go back and she's gonna go see the
one where you put the glasses on and
it's this whole other level and I I
can't handle that [ __ ] you know what I
mean I don't I don't want somebody's
[ __ ] hand in my face and those women
with the [ __ ] the spears there I
don't you know it's enough for me it's
[ __ ] unreal that people needed to
jump off the screen it's like this isn't
incredible enough I don't have ruined
the move there's one fight scene you
know between a couple of fans it's
always family members there's always
some [ __ ] going on you know what I mean
somebody's dad did something or
somebody's pissed at their sister or
they didn't realize you know oh hey I
didn't even know you were my cousin oh
[ __ ] let's join forces and go [ __ ] try
to take the mountain and get the glowing
thing and put it back in its rightful
place so everybody can live in peace
it's basically the blueprint of them
alright my beef with superhero movies is
like after they
made up like six of them kind of like
all the really good ideas were gone it's
like the Duncan contest there's only so
many ways to [ __ ] dunk it and the
next thing you know you know they're
bringing out you know some guy like
staples is sitting at a desk right and
somebody's got to [ __ ] jump over him
use the stapler is like a [ __ ]
springboard or something it's just at
that point you just like dude your other
ideas okay we've we've exhausted what
human beings can do let's wait till
nerds continued to develop these [ __ ]
robots and let's see what they can do
right no you don't think so I don't know
what you guys think of those when you go
to an NBA game and those people come up
with the trampoline and they're all
flipping around and [ __ ] slam on the
ball and everything that was like
interesting for like two weeks and then
I just started realizing that most of
them were white and I just started
feeling bad about myself going Jesus
Craig and do what black people do unless
we had like a [ __ ] trampoline and I
hate whatever form of entertainment that
is dead [ __ ] excitement that they're
trying to pass on to you I'm just too
much of a jaded [ __ ]
you know when they [ __ ] have their
eyebrows up you know and they [ __ ]
not and as they come up you know like
all of a sudden we're all in band camp
or something oh god why am i such a [ __ ]
why can't I just sit and [ __ ] enjoy
things I try I don't try this is just
naturally who the [ __ ] I am you know
what I mean anyways so Saturday night I
had a great weekend Saturday night I
went to the [ __ ] I went to Queens of
the Stone Age at the LA forum with royal
blood opening up Jesus Christ what a
[ __ ] show you have to go see it you
got to go see it it's been I have a
bitter nothing but great things on this
about this tour coming up so I was
really excited in every [ __ ] time
those that band was in town I've been
out of town every [ __ ] time they
played The Wiltern I was out of town
where the health of a people then they
played then their next album came out
and I think well it's staples I don't
know where
we're at naught this album the album
before and I forget where I wasn't in
town so I missed that one and then I
thought I was gonna miss this one at
then in the last second you know my
daughter got sick so I kind of pushed
back my trip to New York and I was able
to go down and see the holy [ __ ] were
they [ __ ] good it was ridiculous and
John Theater has like this [ __ ] red
Vista like KITT now that just sounded
incredible in two times he took a drum
solo
I don't know ruin the show if they do it
the same thing every night they don't
strike me as that kind of band but like
and it was just it was [ __ ] unreal it
was just unreal that bass player was a
bad total [ __ ] rock star and I got to
see royal blood - I'm a big fan of and I
mean Del Ray got there got there a
little bit late but we caught like half
of their set it's just two [ __ ]
people bass player and drums killing it
everybody going nuts and I always loved
seeing shows that though out loud that
the the forum - because I can't believe
like how small that places compared to
like the Staples Center which is like
gigantic and I probably the forum holds
just as many people there's just not so
many bells and whistles in there and
every time I go in there I just look
down where the floor used to be being
like this is where magic worthy Kareem
that's what Mikael somewhere in one of
these corners clothesline Kurt Rambis
this is where the the [ __ ] 76ers came
in and kicked the [ __ ] out of the Lakers
in 83 this is where that piston team
beat the Lakers I think like so many I
mean the Lakers were basically in the
finals almost every year they were in
the finals an 80 82 83 84 85 I might be
wrong about that 86 they missed it 87
and 88 so what is that that was like
seven out of eight was like six out of
eight years of seven out of eight years
they were in the finals every [ __ ]
year so I just think of all the wars
that I saw
on that Court and and I actually saw the
Lakers and the LA Kings play there back
in the 90s I saw the Kings when they
played the Penguins against Mario
Lemieux and then I saw a young young
young Kobe Bryant when he was still
wearing them by eight Dell Harris was
the coach and I think Dennis Rodman was
on that team and Shaq had just got that
Hey ladies
hey you want to talk about that you know
all of the Instagram people I saw at the
mall I didn't tell you I was so friggin
claustrophobic with the how many people
there that was bananas right yeah but I
was telling the listeners that for Lent
I gave up arguing with you Lent Lana's
not to be late but why not 40 days I'm
not gonna argue with you
so right now if you want it you know you
can get it no any any of any of like
[ __ ] that you know that it hopes any
stuff sorry sweetheart
sorry hi
hi my daughter got her ears pierced I
was so against it yeah she does
I know but she's just doing anyway why I
would I was wondering but you might see
something cute won't you put on my
little pork pie hat this is the most
adorable thing you ever watched this now
you're gonna start crooning for us isn't
that Barbra Streisand song Tony he's
saying that too then he scat sing in the
end dooby doo there were my moms at the
mall what's wrong with that
I don't have a prom with it you're right
I don't know what to I don't know what
it was it was five gasps if you're not
gyno
just I wonder I guess I guess you knows
what you was saying I was just wondering
like how committed like are you
it just seems really self-involved like
yeah like I mean I can't get a Tampa
let's say I could get a ten all right
oh you almost felt like you so like say
like I'm a dad and I'm walking around
I got a p90x body all tanned up I got my
teeth all uh all white yeah all whitened
but used hair plugs and all that face
all yank back let me just say okay okay
and I'm walking around now how much do
you think I'm paying attention to my
kids listen I think the better you feel
about yourself the better you are as a
parent that was that would have crushed
on Oprah you clapping for mommy because
I'm right to take the microphone this is
definitely I didn't stop the recorder
did I know obviously if you are choosing
you know do you talking to the mic I'm
watching her good hi if you're like you
know I would play with my child for five
more minutes but I have to do my I don't
know I don't like to judge people but I
think it's cool that you can like have
yourself together and look amazing and
still go out with the kid and like do
your thing I think that's great do you
realize that if I didn't judge people we
both be homeless that's all I do
I told them how I passed out in a black
panther and I thought I was in a
helicopter crash you did pass out but to
be fair you started boozing before we
went and I had one glass it was a big
glass it's a big-boy glass yeah anyway
you had a business you had a big glass
and then you know we did the other thing
I was pretty faded no I wasn't even
buzzed off of that you were walking down
the street you were that was what you
had that psycho weed I always forget to
just take a hit and a half I don't have
like a week yeah yeah I am and I went in
there and all of a sudden this is my
brother and I was just tripping yeah and
then I passed out and at that spaceship
or something crashed did you feel it
[Laughter]
wasn't what I what you saw I really
enjoyed the acting was great
I like the evil brother I'm going to see
it an evil brother an evil white dude
was gray so I like the evil brother to
actually I don't feel like I don't want
to spoil it for those yeah let's stop
talking about all right I guess it only
just came out but um I'm gonna go see it
again tomorrow and 4dx have you ever
heard of this what are they gonna do
there it's like a universal ride where
the seats move and maybe they with the
garden hose I don't really feel like
it's necessary for all that so I'm glad
we saw the race I'm glad we saw the
regular version cuz so I could really
concentrate on the story okay so what
are they gonna do they're gonna like
throw stuff at you I have no idea we'll
see it's like Gallagher meets going to
the movies yeah Gallagher's got great
material and nobody understood I'm
telling you that that sledge-o-matic was
ironic he was making fun of advertising
and then everybody took it at face value
I hope it takes a big thing of cottage
cheese and I get hit in the face with it
yeah they didn't get it with uh what are
you giving me anyways yeah let me do I
got to read a little bit of the the
advertising all right well we came in to
say Oh to say goodnight and a prayer
what song was that well J everyday I was
you know Lawrence workshop
become true and it's how white a guy I
am the other you married a dios or of
wha are wiedersehen
goodnight and then they'd come in with
that the end of the Lawrence Welk Show
that was basically our Soul Train black
people's souls Soul Train from that was
their souls right looks well yeah your
naptime hey is that the sorry is that
the guy that Fred Armisen would make fun
of like do invitation of on on SNL and
then like Kristen Wiig would come out as
the like weird woman with like the
little hands it might no I don't there
was nobody little hands on Lawrence Welk
no I know but I'm just saying I don't
know I don't know what Lawrence Welk is
that definitely sounds like some white
shirt cool whoa y'all excited you're
walking around what do you what's so
funny she just cracks up to herself like
all day long I know I want to be like
what do you think what is out of place
in the universe that it just struck you
as funny I remember when she was like
super super little she'd just be
crawling along and then she just stop
and just go key key key key key like she
just has her own little secret thing
going on it's just kind of she has an
imagination all right let me I gotta
read some waiver ties
just gonna touch the mixer okay hey
beautiful
P say bye-bye I'll see you I haven't
seen the Marcus a kiss
yeah yeah thank you honey can you say
bye bye bye bye alright bye bye oh I
have to sing them the undie song and she
can't be in here for this okay hi daddy
is a an idiot and he makes money saying
filthy fix alright alright see you later
bye fly all right come on these people
are getting bored Mia they're getting
porn eh eh eh eh
well that's your new thing the scowl
somebody tells you not to do something
you started looking at me like what kind
of authority do you have I know the only
time anybody says my daughter looks like
me is when she's in a bad mood and she
gives somebody a look oh she does look
like Bill yeah okay here we go oh look
who it is everybody me undies no but who
dude do me undies me undies mom is
dressing like a horrible dude dude do me
undies me undies it's run the floor so
she goes through what doctor get some
perked up
take some fast fed sticks in an ellipse
now she's dating somebody two grades
below me uh me undies everybody sorry
you want to look good your underwear and
be comfortable but that perfect balance
is hard to find don't sacrifice style or
comfort check out my undies calm and
find the best pair of underwear in the
world talk about why me undies is the
best underwear you will ever own
feel free to improvise well I have a
pair and I have to tell you
they feel nice on my balls it's weird
it's like am i wearing underwear oh yeah
yes I am
it's like the Wonder Woman jet on your
balls except it's underwear the undies
will be the most comfortable pair of
underwear you will ever own made from
sustainably sourced naturally soft
fabric [ __ ] computer screen come on
that is three times softer than cotton
ultimate feel-good undies for when you
want to feel naked not be naked 100
percent satisfaction guarantee they
guarantee you will love your undies or
your money back
speaking of underwear the worst [ __ ]
underwear commercial is that one way
they have like the construction worker
they're like no pinch no snow stench
it's like Jesus Christ this guy with his
bulldozer nuts I don't need to hear
about that right now me undies has an
exclusive offer just for my listeners
get 20% off your first pair and free
shipping and the undies is so schewe
you will love their underwear they even
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee your
order a you order a pair you order a
pair [ __ ]
and you don't love if you don't love
your first pair you get a full refund
this is a no-brainer to try 20% off free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
what in God's name are you waiting for
to get you 20% off free shipping in
their 100% satisfaction guarantee and
get the best and softest underwear you
will ever own go to me undies dot-com
slash bird that's Maddy's comm slash fur
this is a limited time offer so what and
the [ __ ] are you waiting for start
wearing your best underwear of your life
it changed my life evidently according
to the copy it's time to let me undies
change yours go to me undies dot-com / /
right now you know I shouldn't have said
those things about figure skaters you
know I you know I'm just sick of listen
people [ __ ] bitching you know about
body image and all of that [ __ ] can we
at least agree that there are people
better-looking than other people I don't
know maybe I'm a realist
I know I know I'm riding the bench in
the look department I'm like that hack
they put in at the end of an NBA
and [ __ ] people go nuts if I just get
a [ __ ] bucket I hit a foul shot you
know cuz the home team's up by $30 shave
club everybody Dollar Shave Club
delivers to you everything you need to
look smell and feel your best shampoo
body wash toothpaste and of course the
best razors that you will ever use get
an amazing high-quality shave every
morning from Dollar Shave club's
executive race but the true hero of any
morning routine is there dr. Carver's
shave easy shave butter some of those
thick ease you want a figure skate I
think they put it between their thighs
when they get out there and they end up
being too powerful for the old white
judges that's not what beauty looks like
it looks like me it looks like me it
helps the razor gently glide across your
skin you have to experience it another
must have experience is how Dollar Shave
Club delivers everything to you speaking
of which I really like [ __ ] Mary Lou
Retton back in the day I thought she had
a nice body
my mother was tell me I think she's a
little too she's a little too powerful
looking that means no more trips to the
store wandering wandering the aisles
hunting for razors shampoo toothpaste
but then having to play at being a
cashier scanning and bagging your own
stuff God knows I [ __ ] hate that for
a mind-blowing experience join Dollar
Shave Club today all right take it down
Dollar Shave Club all right it's [ __ ]
convenient so I'm going to blow your
mind yeah believe I ordered so many came
to my house it's like everything on the
internet whatever they're saying it's
gonna be mind-blowing they must have
some [ __ ] a shaver or something that
they throw in as a free thing and for
just $5 with Free Shipping you'll get
the six bladed executive razor plus
trial sizes of shave butter body
cleanser and one light one white Chao
then keep the blades coming for a few
bucks a month get yours at
dollarshaveclub.com
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / you know what I
saw today that was [ __ ] no two days
ago was [ __ ] hilarious
this woman in like either a Fiat 500 or
a [ __ ] one of those cars those
British cars a Mini Cooper smashed into
a pole and like literally knocked her
front [ __ ] tire off and there was no
other person involved in the accident
and it reminded me of that old game that
I used to play called older Asian
stamps.com
because there was nobody else around
this person they must have been on the
phone
stamps.com is the easiest way to to
across don't do access I got to get
classic stamps calm is the easiest way
to access all the amazing services of
the post office print postage for any
mail class right from your own computer
the exact amount of postage every time
never under pay or over pay again I'm
gonna use my soothing voice in this
stamps comm saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
I can mail any letter in any package
using just my computer and printer in
but the mailman comes and picks it up
it's actually a woman the mail woman can
we say mail person are you ashamed of
being called a woman stamps calm brings
all the amazing services of the post
office right to your fingertips
buy and print official US postage for
anyone any package any class of mail
using your own computer and they'll send
you a digital scale automatically it
automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps com will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs I use stamps calm whenever I
send out my posters if I'm gonna [ __ ]
myself out at the end of my [ __ ]
shows I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure out
how to do it then so can you and right
now you too can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
include a four-week trial plus postage
and a digital state scale go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and tighten in bur that
stamps commenter burg you know what now
I feel bad that I made fun of figure
skaters because November seeing this
African American woman and she was out
there killing it doing backflips and
[ __ ] and they couldn't deal with how
[ __ ] strong she was and they're like
that's not what a woman looks like so I
felt bad for her I guess I just don't
feel bad for Tonya Harding you don't I
mean then I don't buy that she didn't
know it you know what I mean if
somebody's gonna go out of their way one
of those guys was gonna go out of their
way to smash somebody's knee so you
would win they're gonna let you know
because they're obviously trying to [ __ ]
you right that would have been my
argument if I was the prosecution what
kind of guy goes out and breaks the knee
of another woman for another woman
without telling her I mean he's a guy
all right
he's a heterosexual guy I mean it's
somewhere there has to be a [ __ ] at
the end of the rainbow or he's not
getting out of bed in the morning no
further questions all right gun control
everybody on jj's I stepped into it with
this one I'm trying to see if we can
just somebody can just explain to me I'm
open-minded about it because I don't
know [ __ ] about guns why you need an
ar-15 to [ __ ] defend your house do
people break into your house in packs of
40 that's all I'm asking or is it is it
better in a tight spot you know my big
thing with any gun is how loud is it you
know how loud is the lugs I don't know
if my ears are already [ __ ] up you
know what I mean I can't even just a cap
gun I think I'm gonna go with just like
bear mace you know all right
gun control I love it you spray mace and
then the guys still coming at ya then
you got to run through the cloud that
you just [ __ ] sprayed now you both
[ __ ] can't see [ __ ] all right gun
control here we go Billy red balls of
fire a huge fan and love your work much
respect and enjoy your success thank you
thank you thank you I'm a lifetime NRA
member and I believe in the Second
Amendment now Jesus [ __ ] Christ we get
it
I'm a Metallica fan and I like to rock
can we not be so [ __ ] redundant jesus
[ __ ] christ Kate but but being that
it is an amendment we could change it to
correct it for today's of every day
events and happenings all right these
school shootings could be narrowed down
if we would do away with the salt rifles
and I know there's a lot of gun people
right now going this isn't a real gun
person this is somebody some liberal
[ __ ] hippie he glued a beard to his
face he rented a bass boat and then he
sanded this in trying to act like he
speaks for me he does not all right
these school shootings could be narrowed
down if we would do away with assault
rifles yes there would still be violence
in schools but a 20 or 12-gauge shotgun
is a lot harder to hide than a
nine-millimeter Glock I also have a good
idea right now you can go to a bet to a
Bass Pro Shop Walmart and half a dozen
other stores to buy ammo since here in
New York we have to register our guns
annually we could also make a state-run
ammo only store state-run okay a
state-run ammo only store kind of like
Canada's beer liquor store buy your guns
wherever register them with the state
annually and buy your ammo through the
state that way any large or odd ammo
purchases would be tracked along with
your background check it's really the
best idea I can come up with
as always hello to the lovely Nia and
thank you for putting up with his ginger
ass and Bill go [ __ ] yourself that's
hilarious
all right so there's some ideas there's
some ideas all right is okay mass
shooting proposals hey there wiliest of
bills here's my proposal to reduce mass
shootings get communities to come
together it seems like a simple idea but
here's my logic how many people interact
with or even know their neighbors my
parents divorced when I was four years
old and during my alternating custody I
noticed a few major differences in their
individual happiness and one of them my
minor deeds and one
of the minor details period was my
mother always made it a point to say hi
to her neighbors and hand out cards on
the holidays where my father avoided
neighbors at all costs something me and
also was talking [ __ ] and saying
negative things also sounds like me as
an adult I don't dole out gifts but I do
make it a point to say hi and shoot the
[ __ ] with all my neighbors I believe if
communities regularly interacted or even
held monthly or seasonal events like
block parties they could build a trust
independence for each other and if you
notice a neighbor kid acting shady
it could be noted and the kid could get
the help they need it without feeling
disconnected and abandoned as I said
it's a simple solution as much as I'm a
simple man may one or more gods or fewer
bless you and your family and go [ __ ]
yourself PS I was raised around people
of the LDS faith Mormons and I see these
interactions between them regularly
anecdotal evidence or not it's an idea
all right okay gun response I just want
to hear what people have to say I
usually comment on the shows haven't
really I don't because I don't know [ __ ]
about this I guess that's what it is no
one has been able to tell me why you
need yeah I just was a gun owner would
be [ __ ] honest when it comes to
assault rifles why do you want in us
what do you need an assault rifle for
it's like I don't need one it's just
[ __ ] awesome to just go down to the
gun range right and just [ __ ] have a
good time with it it's like who needs a
[ __ ] Ferrari nobody right nobody
needs a [ __ ] Ferrari all you need is
a guy tell you to [ __ ] the Prius to
get to work but who doesn't want a
Ferrari they're awesome but in the wrong
hands
all right gun responds Billy banned
bullets I never said too bad but just
love the podcasts like that you're a
very humble guy I'm completely full of
myself sir doing stand-up at night is
not enough I have to still have a
microphone on my hands even in my house
okay I love I grew up in South Alabama
and I'm just getting out of the Marine
Corps officer training stereotypically
I'm a conservative with the moderate
knowledge of guns so to answer your
question the second
is to protect yourself and others from
tyranny exactly that's why the with that
other guys saying that only the state
should give out the bullets that debt I
didn't like because I don't trust not
like I don't touch the government man
just the way that it's set up right now
it's just I don't know it's just it's
not it's not a good thing if only the
people who are in control have the
weapons yeah I just don't think that you
know we already see what it's like if
only the people in control owned
basically all the major news sources you
see what it's done to this [ __ ]
country if you [ __ ] paying attention
how few things you can talk about which
is why everybody is sitting around
talking and calling everybody heroes and
this and that and [ __ ] this person is
brave and this person is a bad person a
bubble bubble blah it's like well
they've turn us all into like we all
went back to school like we're sitting
on a [ __ ] playground and we have
major goddamn problems that nobody's
talking about you know I'm off my high
horse okay stereotypically I'm concerned
okay seems far-fetched but look up
deaths from government tyranny in the
last century semi-automatic rifles like
the armor like 15 I guess that's the
ar-15 aka the ar-15 yep are the minimum
needed firepower for a guerrilla militia
to fight organized militaries ar-15 is
not a military grade weapon or assault
rifle by official standards the main
reason being effective firing range
pistols are almost as effective at close
range so a ban on a ours won't do much
if anything for most of these horrible
events and will eliminate purpose of
Second Amendment well I mean no oh now
wait a minute dude wait a minute the how
much how fast you can shoot and how many
people you can [ __ ] hit I mean if you
walk into a crowded area how good a shot
do you have to be I just which one of
these gun people just be a listen I
don't want to ban an ar-15 because I'm
not [ __ ] crazy and I enjoy shooting
the
and woods up with this thing it's fun I
just there has to be a way it just can't
be that [ __ ] easy for a [ __ ]
lunatic to get their hands on because
the bottom line is there's nothing wrong
with guns as long as you're not a
[ __ ] lunatic but the problem is is
it's obviously too easy as a lunatic to
get one does that make sense to gun
people noncom building guns are [ __ ]
great like I can guarantee I have a
baseball bat under my bed and I can
guarantee you if anybody came my house
what's the one [ __ ] thing I would
wish that I had I wish I had a [ __ ]
gun
you know Mike my wife doesn't like him
she's afraid of him which I get now we
got a kid so I'm not you know I'm not
gonna [ __ ] do that you know I you
know and I also don't think you know if
you get you know I turn it everybody
turning their [ __ ] guns the only
people gonna do that are honest people
what are bad people gonna be like well I
guess we gotta turn in our [ __ ] guns
I just there has to be some sort of I
don't know how the [ __ ] do you figure
out who's [ __ ] nuts or not that's the
problem
anyway subsequent subsequently almost
all gun deaths are from pistols solution
and creatures increased the age of legal
purchase to 21 for anything except pump
action shotguns and black-powder rifles
pistols you already have to be 21 okay
also armed security at schools not a
cure-all but better than nothing yeah
why don't they have armed people at
schools you know I wouldn't have a
problem with that by the way founding
fathers had a concept of machine guns
and certainly of semi-automatic they
weren't using micro aggressions you Cali
Lib what do you mean they had a concept
I have a concept of a flying [ __ ] car
do I know what that's going to do to the
world
I hope all that clarifies a point of
view without being too in-depth thanks
for question you're for questioning your
stance on the issue
what was there what was their concept
and how do you know they had a concept
did new evidence show that they had this
what do they have beyond with that with
that first one that came up with where
it had to be like pushed by nine people
and then he had your little cranky did
you did you you know then the guy who
came up with the machine gun he wanted
to do that to lower deaths I heard that
some other [ __ ] I heard like he was
just like well this thing can shoot as
much as an entire platoon so you won't
have to have a platoon then he can have
less people in the army because this
person's gonna be shooting just as much
and then all the sickos at the top were
like that we will have a platoon a
platoon with all machine guns and it
just keeps that's that's war that's a
completely different [ __ ] thing I'm
gonna go out on a limb and I don't think
the founding fathers had a concept of
what the [ __ ] of the the level of
population I mean there's just so much
was [ __ ] different back then that they
had the concept of an ar-15 and a
[ __ ] food court in the 1700s I you
know maybe they did I mean they weren't
they were pretty you know I don't know
flying kites with keys on them um I
guess that makes you a smart guy I don't
know all right all right gun yeah but I
like this because nobody's telling me to
go [ __ ] myself or anything like that you
noticed people when you just sort of ask
what you're thinking people will then
act civilized as opposed to all you
idiots not [ __ ] I shouldn't say
opposed you all of human individuals who
all have a right to your opinion the way
you guys address each other on social
media is you know I don't know it's just
the quickest way to have an a vein
popping out of your forehead all right
gun ESPN Billy musket mug I don't know
what that means this funny you write
about the media turning the shootings
into ESPN for killers then the number
they keep throwing around is 18 this
year they're counting suicides a time
where a gun went off in a car another
was a kid who pulled a police officers
trigger in class here's an article about
it no I was saying that when the mass
shootings the way the way they say like
this is the deadliest this is the third
deadliest this is the most
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
and then they splatter the person's face
all over the [ __ ] news and I just
don't think that they should show the
person they should die anonymously and
that's it I would even like not even
cover the [ __ ] story I mean the
people that need to know know people
that lost people who had people affected
by it okay and I don't know to go beyond
that then what am I sitting there
watching it for so I can watch people
cry and see people with the worst day of
their [ __ ] life why do I need to know
that that that happened okay
law enforcement is gonna get the person
they're gonna [ __ ] prosecute them and
all of that type of [ __ ] why do I need
to know that that is going on I can't
defend myself against it I'm not gonna
go do it right however if you're some
sicko when you're watching that [ __ ] you
know I think sickos watch those stories
the way you know I used to watch rock
bands and it made me want to play drums
alright non-americans view on guns I'm
of the opinion that the occasional mass
killing in the u.s. is the price you pay
for your government not turning in into
Hitler's Germany or Stalin's Russia it
might be the only thing keeping your
government from going full [ __ ] my
country new zeal New Zealand might be
protected in turn by the stability of
the USA I I'm texting I must be way
smarter than I am I don't want the
[ __ ] that means I'm in the opinion
that the occasional mass killings is the
you USA in the USA is the price you pay
for your government not turning into
Hitler's Germany or Stalin's Russia so
because we're we're allowed to be freer
than them the price we pay is that is
that what you're saying and it might be
the only thing keeping your government
from going full [ __ ]
which if you look at the economics of
the war that we're fighting it has
because I don't know how we keep doing
this
or while we're throwing this much money
you know I don't know you know why the
[ __ ] we're doing it everybody does all
right lifting weights hey Bill I'm a
longtime fan of the podcast just wanted
to respond to your comment about not
lifting weights well it's a great that
you recognize the negatives of lifting
weights as a primary routine I would not
count out curling a few dumbbells every
now and then there's been a lot of
research about the cardiovascular
benefits to basic weightlifting I
suggest lower weight high reps at least
once a week thank you i 100% agree with
that all right but the problem is as I
came up in the 80s so it's all about
dude what are you benching and how I got
hurt was one time in my life I was able
to put up to 25 which is two 45s on both
sides I finally felt like a big boy in
the gym so like an [ __ ] whenever I
first hurt myself which I think I was 48
you know I hear ago this past October so
that would be 20 in October 2016 I had a
[ __ ] gym put in I was all excited and
I [ __ ] the first day [ __ ] up my
shoulder and I'd never done it before so
I just tried to push through it and I
kept lifting and now it's just
completely it's completely [ __ ] up and
every time I think I'm getting towards
the end of it like I have you know I now
have this strength back where I can like
you know pick up [ __ ] and everything but
my mobility is really [ __ ] up so I
haven't been to the physical therapy in
a minute I gotta get back to that I just
got a little busy here
but I agree with that 100% use it or
lose it but you know don't try to
[ __ ] lift what you lifted when you
were 20 all right my wife is nuts
hey guys keep fussing and [ __ ] in about
the gun control stuff because I think
it's really interesting as far as like
you know to just hear people's opinions
and where they're from and why they view
stuff the way they do without [ __ ]
screaming at each other and hopefully
you know I don't know I I just can
somebody way in how okay whether you're
pro-gun are not pro-gun all right how
you know cuz psychos do a lot of [ __ ]
psychos getting cars and they drive into
[ __ ] people and all of that [ __ ] you
know what I mean they don't try to [ __ ]
or make take cars away from everybody I
know that's overly simplifying it but
you know I think it's I don't know I
just don't even know I'm not into guns I
just don't look at him like that these
these [ __ ] like they're alive and
they have the devil in him
I do find them scary you know I have
gone to gun ranges and I shoot and it's
fun once you kind of it's like anything
first started flying a helicopter I was
like is this thing gonna chop my [ __ ]
head off and then once you get into the
physics and how the whole thing works it
becomes absolutely fascinating so you
know I think those people go skeet shoot
and I think that's the [ __ ] and I think
people that hunt is it's [ __ ] amazing
that they know how to do that and build
a fire and survive outside it's probably
an important thing that you need to know
how to do I respect all of that [ __ ]
it's just how does so and those people
should be allowed to continue doing that
I just wish there was a [ __ ] way that
you could figure out when somebody came
up to be like maybe that's there
something good for a LexA is everybody
bugs their house right maybe one of
those [ __ ] lunatics will be muttering
to themselves you know what God knows I
have a little camera in there and I'll
see the person [ __ ] bringing all this
[ __ ] ammo I don't know even then just
seeing if you limited the amount of
ammunition the amount of [ __ ] damage
that you can do just by I would think
just buying a box of bullets it's
[ __ ] nuts I didn't like talking about
it it's so [ __ ] creepy
all right life is tough but I appreciate
everybody calmly discussing this and I
respect all of your pins all right life
is nuts bill longtime listener of the
podcast dude can you shed a light on why
my wife is unable to have a real
conversation about anything tangible
politics current events music sports etc
I swear she has no interest outside of
her work and trashy TV teen mom TLC
shows etc it's
has said she used to be so interesting
but now that she's a mom she's a bore
well she's tired man life is just not
fun to her I love being a father but I
just since she can't handle the life
side of her life what gives
she's a fantastic mother to her son but
is mailing it in as a wife all right I'm
not gonna lie to you I've run into these
kinds of problems all right
you know [ __ ] changes obviously when you
have a kid but with a woman they like I
don't know what the [ __ ] going there
you have like thunder and lightning
going on in between their [ __ ] ears
like all hormones and all this crap and
they get a c-section they got to recover
from major abdominal surgery they going
through a lot of stuff plus you know
their body literally changes they put on
weight and [ __ ] and it's like so easy to
fall into a depression get overwhelmed
and all of that type of [ __ ] so I would
say you know you're doing the guy thing
well you just bare bones talking about
it going she unable to have a real
conversation about anything tangible I
can tell you why my wife watches trashy
TV she sometimes just doesn't want to
think okay and you know the level of
worry that they have you know but what's
going to happen the kid am i doing a
good job and all that type of [ __ ] what
you need to do you need to have a date
night once a week once every two weeks
get a sitter and go out and kind of get
that going again all right and I think
your wife will enjoy you guys will enjoy
each other's company you got to have you
know most of your life is gonna be about
the kid but you got to have that one
little thing right that's what I would
do and all the [ __ ] that you said to me
I would not say to her so anyways that
is the that is a park Oh did anybody see
when the the Bruins played the Calgary
Flames at home and they had the reunion
of the 1977-78 Boston Bruins that set a
record even though they lost
back-to-back years to the Canadiens of
the finals [ __ ] heartbreaking losses
but that team had like the most 20 or
more goal scorers on it and all of these
guys I hadn't seen in like right when I
started watching hockey these guys were
the Bruins it was Wayne Cashman Terry
O'Reilly Stan Jonathan Peter McNabb that
was Gene Mattel is John Mattel he was
gone by the time I I started watching
John Wensink was gone Bob we just talked
about the 20 goal scorers yeah Rick
Middleton he was one of my favorites
they did this great thing where they had
they just brought him back and they was
showing all the highlights and they had
Don Cherry come out he was the coach at
the time and it was so [ __ ] great to
see those guys and he did all these
interviews and laugh and they're all
[ __ ] that hockey plays of the [ __ ] it
was just for the most part just humble
and that type of thing and they will
laugh and like stand your honor the a
you are known as a tough customer it's
one of the toughest [ __ ] guys that
ever played and he's like yeah you know
I had a couple of scraps or whatever
just you know whatever doesn't need to
prove anything
and I actually only watched the first
period we played horrible defense in
that game I hopefully [ __ ] ended up
winning that but I'm trying to hang in
there with the Bruins and the Celtics I
know I haven't been talking about it
much this year but uh my kid became
mobile so I spend most of my life
running around after her and when she
goes to sleep I sleep you know what I
mean
it's like that Ludacris song right when
you move when I move you move well
that's the other way when she sleeps you
sleep just like that well you see
whatever the [ __ ] song is that's what
I was saying when I put it down well you
sleep I sleep just like dad she goes hee
hee hee and she [ __ ] laughs and falls
asleep and then I shut my eyes which
feels like five seconds
I don't have to wake back up again which
is probably why I fell asleep during the
phenomenal black panther go out check it
out
really enjoyed that movie even though I
fell asleep and thought I was in a
helicopter crash
all right that's it and my apology to
figure skaters you know what I mean why
do you have to be skating around all
[ __ ] emaciated you don't so I think
it's about time they got some Vicki's
out there all right
God knows maybe they can do some new
tricks okay that's it that's the podcast
I'm off to New York and I'm gonna do
that benefit looking forward to seeing
Bobby Kelly rich Voss Joe DeRosa all the
people out there shoutout to Colin Quinn
I know he's doing better and all that
stuff he's been to just about every
Patrice O'Neal benefit salt of the earth
guy so giving him a shout out so
hopefully he'll be up and around
I can run into him in New York and try
and break his balls all right that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves or check in T
check in with you on Thursday Jesus